That's right Lauren. Cortisol is a hormone produced by the body and it is
important to give us fuel during emotional arousal and stressful events.
However, cortisol is also a part of the immune system functioning and it
decreases the number of immune cells available in the blood stream to fight off
infection. Therefore, when we are stressed we are more likely to get sick. As
an example, when I was getting ready to write this lesson, I became very sick.
I got a terrible cold. I was really stressed. I had to write this lesson. I was
behind in my grading. I had theses to review. And on top of it, my poor cat,
Nonsense, was sick. It's no doubt, then, or surprising, why students get sick
around mid-term and finals. The important thing to remember here, is that when
we experience a stressful event, cortisol is released, which decreases our
immune system functioning. Now, we're going to go to Greg, and look at how we
handle stress.